I am at the soulmate of my life she's
great she's fantastic
when she looked like I I know I haven't
met you yet or seeing you or know what
you smell like but I I picked your
daisies no I don't know what she looks
like because we wanted to keep it a
little spicy I met it through a social
networking website called Asian
persuasion so recently she messaged me
on Facebook I got a little excited um
we're gonna meet each other tomorrow in
downtown and I am going to be meeting
her up next to the old railroad museum
it's gonna be great and she will not be
disappointed
at all I guarantee it am i excited I
don't know there's a scroll get excited
when he sees a cashew
over here waiting for Ana she said this
should be here by 3:30 so long where she
is
so I'm really just stick
should you survive a good man nowadays I
mean
getting really kickin you why you
looking at me like Allah because you are
a liar you're a liar that you have an
athletic body building I'm a sumo
wrestler have you seen sumo wrestle
before I'm now in your dream you know
what how did you even get you you're 60
years old I want to have you ever locked
it yes I have fun you know what you
won't call me fat haha you know what
stupid ana what hate your guts if you co
op yeah so well looks like you're
walking down fat ass
a sumo wrestler is an athlete so your
countries you don't like Japanese people
I know exactly you know what you're
racist I'm call your mom
each little gasps yeah I don't you know
how did you get here
wow those are shots like that life have
you ever walked inside a Siamese - whoa
whoa whoa whoa we're coming fan hi